hunter hunter is dead ish dead ish which
means that it's also alive ish alivish
i suppose it's time that we have a very
serious discussion hello and welcome to
the new world review your source for
everything anime and manga my name is
liam and happy new year new worldian
people what i'd love to tell you is that
we have a very exciting content packed
year planned ahead but that wouldn't be
well that wouldn't be entirely the truth
would it it's time to have a frank
honest and perhaps even painful
discussion regarding our beloved hunter
hunter a series that despite its
complete and utter absence from the
world still manages to capture hundreds
of thousands of views on this channel it
is both shocking and humbling to be part
of this life support fanbase and while i
don't plan on stopping with hunthunter
anytime soon we do have we have a bit of
a big problem because it has now been
over three years since the last chapter
of hunter hunter was published making
this by far the longest hiatus that the
fan base has ever endured and whilst i
do enjoy the idea of you know it always
being darkest before dawn and all that
kind of stuff it is hard to deny this
feeling of bleak abandonment so we're
going to distract ourselves with a quick
round of togashi gone a very simple
mini-game the rules of which are as
follows yoshihiro togashi is hiding
behind one of these three gones and it's
going to be our job to guess which is
the one where togashi himself has gone
now should you guess incorrectly then
your punishment will be to subscribe to
the new world review thus resulting
consistent injections of hunter-based
culture being administered directly into
your youtube feed and if you are correct
then you can pat yourself on the back
and and no no have a wank
i don't care what you do pick an
activity of your choosing if you're
correct so where is togashi choose your
gon now and we shall reveal the answer
in three two one and bam it was none of
them because in this case togashi is
truly gone so if you guessed incorrectly
and that should be most of you except
for a couple of smart asses then you
know the thing to do and please do say
hi in the comments below if you are a
new member of the association welcome so
what's the situation well as i said we
are now in the beginning of our fourth
hiatus year and for some fun numbers
there in 2021 hunt under celebrated i
mean celebrate it is probably not the
right word but hunt under celebrated
having exactly 1 000 days without having
published a chapter and for some context
conversely in 2021 one piece celebrated
publishing 1 000 chapters as well as 100
mark volumes and 1 000 anime episodes
and remembering that hunter hunter is
only a year younger than one piece this
was definitely quite the bittersweet
occasion oh and here's a bonus fun fact
this channel the new world review
started covering hunter hunter in june
2019. meanwhile the last published
chapter of hunter hunter was released on
november 26 2018. so weirdly enough new
world review has never been making
content at the same time that any hunt
hunt media has been published so this
channel is i suppose acting as a true
gap filler pumping your veins full of
delicious hunter proteins until the
hopeful return of our lord and savior
speaking of let's have our annual
togashi update where has this man been
since november 2018. that was an
unintentional rhyme but the answer is
surprisingly nowhere other than hunter
hunter the last recorded work we have of
togashi was his collaboration on akutan
wars which is fascinating because
togashi wrote the story whilst it was
illustrated by hachi mizuno and i go to
the trouble to point that out because it
almost feels like a test run for
continuing hunter hunter we'll get into
this in a bit but there is a huge call
for hunter hunt to proceed with a new
artist handling the illustrations whilst
togashi provides the raw story elements
so it is interesting that we do have an
example of such collaboration even if it
hasn't amounted to anything as of yet
although in fact maybe that's the reason
why we haven't heard anything yet
perhaps togashi hated this experience
and has doubled down on his philosophy
as for a physical sighting though
togashi was spotted in august 2018
attending a karakazaka 46 concert which
is one of those mega rider groups that i
think has a different name now but
thinks something along the lines of
akb48 but it's just probably not as good
not that i know what's good i don't
follow idol groups interesting that
togashi is an idol fan interesting not
surprising he fits the stereotype quite
well about a year later in april 2019
togashi made a recorded public
appearance at a restaurant named
framatic which we know because he drew
them a shikishi featuring ghan a very
well drawn gone i might add which is
notable because his medical issues make
drawing even simple art quite difficult
oh and he was also there with his wife
nyokutakuchi who also drew a sailor moon
shigishi as she is the author of sailor
moon so i'd be pretty damn pleased to
fire with that restaurant having two
heavy hitters of the manga world enjoy
your food so much that they turn your
walls into manga history next togashi
was seen in september 2019 attending the
yu hakusho stage play and at the show a
fan asked them to sign their ticket to
which tagashi generously obliged however
this is where i guess i get a bit
concerned because unlike the flawless
image of gone at the restaurant yusuke
here looks like he's been quite a
difficult task to pump out and i don't
want to go too deeply into this because
i don't know maybe togashi just had to
draw him on a very uneven surface or
something like that but it's still a bit
of an artistic shock to go from gone to
yusuke and i think this is definitely an
indicator of the aforementioned medical
issues and then in december 2019 we
received the sort of news that we have
been waiting for although it was not
good news on twitter someone posted
their interaction with an editor from
shueisha to whom they directly asked
about the status of hunt hunter and this
tweet read as such my colleagues just
casually asked about how he was doing
when the editors from shueisha came and
if there were any plans on bringing back
hunter hunter anytime soon they said
that he is still suffering from back
pain so no further plans just yet that
was december 2019 and to the best of my
knowledge we've neither seen nor heard
anything at all since to be fair if
there were a set of ears to be missing
from the world 2020 and 2021 are most
understandable togashi was rarely seen
in public when the world was still
functional so it's not surprising that
he's been completely m.i.a over the past
two years and of course shueisha
themselves have kept very tight-lipped
about everything on this matter though
there is an interview from togashi
discussing the future of hunt hunter
pre-hiatus which i think is important to
highlight here because he said they let
me do what i want the series i'm working
on right now might be a huge problem
from a different point of view than mine
but i'm really enjoying it i think there
are two types of readers those who don't
care if i draw my stories or not and
those who want to read a manga written
and illustrated directly by me i still
don't know how to balance this problem
to satisfy the majority of my readers
generally i think it's okay to leave the
illustrations to someone else which i
personally find quite hopeful because
obviously the ideal scenario would be
for tagashi to be magically healed by
nanikar and just continue on his own but
given that this is unfortunately reality
i would be incredibly keen to find the
right artist to bring togashi's story to
life and tagashi while he does seem to
land on that side of the mata was
evidently worried about what fans would
think would they accept a hunter hunter
without his hand guiding the visuals
well we can gauge this because i
conducted a poll on new world review and
the overwhelming majority of people said
that they would be happy for hunt hunter
to return with a new artist maintaining
togashi as the writer and usually i try
to keep polls open for a lot longer than
you know an hour but the avalanche of
responses here made it clear that the
overall percentage was not going to
change radically because whether it's 96
95 or even gasp 94 that is still a very
decisive result with some of the
comments including togashi could
literally just release a dialogue
outline for the rest of the series with
the panels being described in lengthy
paragraphs and i would be more than
happy personally i think i did probably
want a bit more than that but i get you
as long as it's togashi writing the
story i'll be happy but we also have the
very important counterpoint which does
exist and that is i disagree art is part
of his storytelling and i do
begrudgingly agree with this to some
extent writing manga is not like writing
a screenplay or even a play play it's
not done with the thought that you're
gonna hand this work over to someone
else for them to ultimately bring it to
life the manga process evolves in tandem
dialogue is written whilst pages are
constructed and they inform each other
in a very organic process so we would
certainly lose something if togashi were
to hand over the illustration process
things might feel a bit disconnected
because togashi's vision may not match
that of the new artist however we also
stand to gain quite a bit because so
long as we have a trusted talented
artist they could even potentially add a
new dimension to hunter hunter that
could enhance the series so something
like this is always quite high risk high
reward and yes there's always the
question of authenticity and then the
desire for such stuff because is it
really still hunter hunter if it's not
100 togashi and look we could ramble on
about that for all eternity because it's
a very philosophical question what i do
find interesting though is togashi's
author comment for the final chapter
currently released because he said that
he had completed storyboards for a
further 10 chapters so in the very worst
case scenario where hunter hunter never
continues i imagine that those would
probably be released someday and we
might receive a bit of closure as to
where the series was heading and 10
isn't a lot but it also kind of is with
the amount of dialogue and plot that
togashi has just crammed into the
succession war 10 chapters could
actually go an awfully long way and
something we do need to quite
legitimately take into consideration now
though is age when we were discussing
this hiatus three years ago as it first
began age was not a primary concern
however togashi is now 55 years old
which for a mangaka who has been drawing
their entire professional career is well
and truly hitting that retirement zone
sure you do have some seemingly immortal
authors like say hiro hikaraki who is 61
years old and still planning to continue
jojo's bizarre adventure because what a
boss but most authors aren't quite as
durable as him to compare things further
the author of one piece etc oda is only
47. quite the comparative spring chicken
so it's much easier to see one piece
continuing for another five to seven
years unto hunter though even if it does
come off hiatus togashi will be in his
late 50s and with back conditions as
this is not a great combination and i
think that might lead to the question of
would you like to see a continuation of
hunter hunter that has no togashi
involvement at all i didn't do a poll on
this but i feel like the answer would be
much more negative almost like the
kantara miura situation where it's
probably for the best just to leave
berserk alone rather than risk ruining
it but when it comes to hunt hunter my
thoughts are more along the lines of
side stories like say the hisoka one
shot chapter by swee ishida which fun
fact started as an april fool's joke but
the response was so overwhelmingly
positive that shueisha made it happen
for real because that's how ravenous
hunter hunter fans are for any kind of
content so why not give other mangaka
some space to create stories in this
world i think that would be fun in terms
of animated projects there's obviously
not much that can be done without a
solid chunk of story to animate however
there is always hope for a project
surrounding the hisoka vs crawler fight
it's a condensed independent story that
could easily be told over a mini-series
or even a shot ova and i am perpetually
shocked that nothing like this has been
done yet because it's practically a
license to print money fans would go
absolutely insane for something like
that and by the time we do get around to
maybe animating it in an actual anime
series if that ever happens the ova will
be so old that a remake will be
warranted but as for the most important
question i asked all of you whether you
think hunter hunter will return in 2022
and the results are as expected less
than hopeful with over 80 percent of
voters saying no it won't return and 30
throwing their lot in with the idea that
hunter hunter will never return period
so it's definitely an uphill battle at
the moment but good on that 16 for
retaining some kind of optimism and as
for this channel we will continue making
hunt on stuff as long as you want to
watch it as crazy as it is i feel like i
still make new discoveries every time i
go back on the series and somehow there
is always more to talk about so even if
hunter hunter itself remains vacant for
2022 we will remain to provide that fix
starting with this next video because
there's always more to learn explore and
experience with this wonderful series so
i look forward to seeing you there